now how are you doing on your new year's
resolutions be honest because it when it
comes to those resolutions new research
shows that nearly 1/5 of us make and
break the same resolution each and every
year and with more than half of us
saying health goals are the ones that
are hardest to keep why is it so easy to
throw in the towel well one man who
knows all about dedication and
resilience and getting up and going
again and again and again is my next
guest British ski jumper at Michael
Edwards better known as Eddie the Eagle
hello hello I thought he meant failing
all the time no you dig in and you get
on with it and you never give up sit up
straight yeah I got a perfect person to
talk about this and say why are it's so
good at just throwing in the towel and
giving up I think it's mainly to do with
modern living
everybody wants instant results because
everything is instant nowadays and so if
they don't feel a health benefit or they
don't lose enough weight instantly they
give up and I think they should just
just stick with it
maybe if they sort of lower the goal a
little bit sometimes they set goals too
big I'm going to lose 10 stone this year
and I think well initial 50 stone to
start with you're not going to lose 10
stone in here but if you lose one pound
a week one pound in weight which is not
difficult and then at the end of the
year that's 52 pounds that's like 4 and
a half stone so that's a bit easier so
break it down my ponies have a big
long-term goal but make sure you have
little steps as well with my own ski
jumping I start on the little jumps work
my way up to the big ones and that's the
same sort of ethos really think about it
differently and it's the health goals
isn't it the most people tend to Annie
make a fresh start right it's gonna be
an overhaul of mine to my life I'm gonna
quit the booze quit the cigarette start
eating things a little more green rather
than bathe this where's the fun in that
it's almost unrealistic isn't it cause
you can't live like a nun I yeah that's
right and there are times when you you
it's just more convenient to eat fast
food I eat fast food a lot but that's
because of my lifestyle and I haven't
got time to cook something but wherever
I can I eat as much fruit and as much
vegetable as I can so it's sort of
moderation and things like that do a lot
of people think well I've failed I've
I've had a cigarette or I've had a
drinks I say then they Jack the hole
they chat well they go when really
that's just a bit of blip then just
carry on from there and
you know it doesn't mean just but you
just made one blip it means the end of
everything so it's being realistic about
your goals how do you stick to them
because obviously being a being an
athlete you've obviously you know been
single-minded and focused how do you
employ that the likes of my cell from
people watching over it says of having
that mental strength to stick to
something because I'm really fatty I'll
be honest with you well the the little
goals the the weekly goals the monthly
goals help because then it's not such a
big thing to keep looking at the way in
advance you can you can you can
concentrate on on each goal each week
but then also just by declaring to
everybody I'm gonna try and lose weight
or I'm gonna stop smoking or I'm gonna
drink less and things by declaring it
that's the excitement wow I'm gonna
really go for this and also you've told
everybody so that you create a like a
support network that's important as well
so your friends and family know about it
and hopefully they'll support you they
might even join you try January I
suppose that's a big support network
you're doing to meet together that gives
you this week you can support each other
so when you start getting a little bit
way you start to drift a little bit
you've got your friends who can help
support you so that helps with my ski
jumping I had nothing and when I told
people what I wanted to do they were
great they helped me with food they they
let me sleep in their places they drove
me from jump to jump because I didn't
know where they were so having a support
network was was vital so that helps and
then they were there are you know drugs
and things that you can help as well but
not you know terribly drugs it's just
you know like the nicotine patches when
you're going to get smoking there are
things that you can take that actually
help with your mentality and help you
give that strength fixham in supplements
and things easy at least America's
January everybody's feeling a bit mirth
that's why I would go to your pharmacist
and speak to him I want to lose weight
or I want to do this what can I do what
can I take that will help you seek out
help you go to things like Pharma doctor
coat UK they will help as well and look
at their website they will give you as
much support as you can okay that's
really good say get advice from
professionals
seek support from friends and family
yeah so get a good network around you it
was always a good idea to have a
positive resolution rather than a
negative one I know giving up the booze
cigarettes and eating better are all
positive aims but you
poor leaving yourself or something so I
always think if I'm gonna do a
resolution I want to add something
whether it's just I'm going to try and
learn a language which is one that comes
up every year I never do it but I feel
like I'm adding I do a little bit of it
or I go and travel somewhere or I'm
gonna reconnect with friends doing
something positive I think yeah I think
if you have a series of resolutions I
think that helps you might have a
negative one but those are positive ones
as well and for me it's yeah I want to
travel more I want to ski more I'm gonna
dance more I want to do things and do
exciting things that's what I put in my
resolutions but but I'm lucky enough
that I don't smoke I drink probably
about five drinks a year any of the bad
stuff to give up my chocolate I love my
but I try and you know regulate how much
chocolate ie
yeah I don't just eat good all year outs
you don't really need let's face it well
and what did you make this year my
resolution this year is to actually
spend more time trying to meet somebody
because I've been seeking out for five
years and although I love being single
and I love doing stuff it'd be nice to
come home and see somebody and tell them
about my day you know try and find a
partner maybe and that's hunger trying
to do that I fit I feel like I feel like
this could be a good time see you on TV
too you know and make your open to you
have to be in the right frame of mind if
you do and it's 2020 it's a new decade I
think that's even more special so it's
it's been great to talk to you thank you
very much I use it also you know if
you're single